[Applause]
foreign
that's right it's me Tom shallou Greg's
out getting his unibrow tweezed
trust me it takes a while
so there was a time when the phrase you
deserve a break today made hungry people
dream of two old beef patty Special
Sauce lettuce cheese pickles onions on a
sesame seed bun but in light of recent
news from the European Union it looks
like those days are over with a
Vengeance in fact if these globalists
have their way the phrase you deserve a
break today will soon make hungry people
think of this
that's right now when there were
Crickets at Jamie's show they'll be
served with an actual side of crickets
yeah the European Union has just given
the green light for two more species of
insect to be used as food for humans I
know you're thinking someone pinched me
but it's true as of Tuesday a powdered
form of the house Cricket will be given
the green light for human consumption
within the European Union but hold on
don't start licking your chops yet
also approved for human consumption is
the larval form of the meal worm
it's got meal right there in the name
the Netherlands program is pitching the
worms as an alternative form of
nutrition for school children of course
this diabolical plan should come as a
surprise to no one for years now global
Elites have been aiming to move Western
populations away from eating meat I mean
why eat something that's delicious
packed with nutrients totally satisfying
when you could eat something that Mikey
from those cereal commercials wouldn't
even touch
that's a boomer reference isn't it okay
earlier this month the topic was once
again front and center at the world
economic forum's annual conference in
Davos or as the rest of us call it the
casting call for future Bond villains
we caught up with wef chairman Klaus
Schwab to see what he thinks of this
idea yeah he loves this idea of eating
the bugs it's a wonderful idea we had so
many wonderful ideas we discussed as a
recent meeting of the world economic
forum for instance it's a chip in the
head I love the chip in the head uh you
could do so many convenient things with
the chip in the head uh shopping for
instance and we could build your straws
a chip and if you are late with a
payment we could send you a reminder
I'll send you an electronic piles just a
form sensation nothing serious it's just
the same feeling you would get if you
heat it up a fork over an open flame and
stabbed yourself in the temple with it
so it's a convenient remind
wow wow
a chip idea doesn't he okay back to the
bugs the Waf report calls for transition
to Net Zero nature positive food all in
the name of fighting food insecurity you
know what makes me insecure having to
eat something I normally crush with my
heel
so the folks in Davos want you eating
bugs why you think it's about nutrition
no it's about control they're trying to
see how far they can go and look at us
we already put on masks and stood in
those lines with stupid arrows painted
six feet apart on the floor
you know how easy it is to get these
kids to eat a bug
they're trying to shut down independent
farms in the name of global warming but
again it's about controlling the food
supply let's just take a moment to
imagine a world that's consistent with
their joyless agenda shall we instead of
Rolling Green Hills and pastures as far
as the eye can see instead we'll have
solar panel Farms that eke out just
enough power to leave you and your EVS
stranded on the outskirts of town
but don't worry you can still take the
bullet train to Greta thundberg's next
speech
you'll be able to take comfort in the
fact that you're helping the planet
but would you really be helping pretty
soon the starving masses would reach
their inevitable Breaking Point pull up
roots in order to move within Striking
Distance of a Shake Shack
you better get out of their way or
you'll need a private jet to get
someplace safe which is exactly the
point and it's also why now is the
perfect time to make it clear this whole
Twisted plan is only capable of one
thing leaving a bad taste in your mouth
here he is
let's welcome tonight's guests
she's got so much energy Greta thundberg
tries to protest her outnumbered co-host
Emily compagno
he's our absolute favorite wait a minute
what did you do with Joe Mackey
writer and comedian Joe DeVito
she knows more about the economy than
the president of the United States then
again who does it Fox Business anchor
Lawrence Simonetti
and a judge recently ordered his kids to
pay him child support
actor writer and comedian Jamie lithow
well well well very buggy what do you
think Emily uh do you think do you agree
with me that this bug plan is more about
control they say it's about nutrition
what do you think yeah absolutely and I
think it's about putting a Band-Aid over
a hemorrhaging amputated arm which is oh
if we just add larvae mealworms to the
kids diet then everything is going to be
okay while refusing to acknowledge the
source of the issues right there's been
no International
buy-in whatsoever on commercial fishing
on pollution coming out of India and
China there's a lot of things that are
destroying the planet a whole hell of a
lot faster than Americans eating meat or
those in Denmark eating meat so to me I
see this as to your point yes control
and also a shell game with what's really
important I feel like you know when I
when I travel I don't mind eating
anything as long as it's customary like
if someone tells me oh we eat this all
the time then I'll eat it but I'd rather
sort of find out after the fact
um but I think you know the larval
mealworm is really really hard to
stomach yeah it's pun intended they're
trying to sell you pointed it here we
actually do have some of these bugs so
if you want to try them I guess I'll try
the meal worm here pass it around
you don't want to try it Jamie I do not
it's kind of crunchy is it salty it's
not salted but it probably could use it
has a bit of a oh my wait what's in
which one is which this is well the
worm's the worm the worm's the worm I'll
bet it doesn't matter much we've got the
bolt right here you can see it at home
these are the Crickets try the Crickets
aren't you wait seriously yeah don't
spill them Jamie yeah
a lot of time on the road it's hard to
eat well
[Applause]
[Music]
it tastes like
it tastes like sunflower seeds yeah like
a rice crispy like a Rice Krispie like
Jamie we can just hand it out to the
audience to see if they want to Jamie
would you want to eat bugs good I'm so
uncomfortable right now because of those
bugs really if they taste like sunflower
seeds we should eat sunflower seeds
um yeah
I got like thrown for a second um first
of all can I spew can I apologize I want
to apologize when you said crickets and
the camera came to me I was looking away
I should have known that it was coming
my way and when I looked over on the
monitor I saw myself looking and there
was a minute where I was like oh I can
get back before they see and
um that's impossible I think this is
kind of exciting I think we're finally
finally finding a solution to this
problem that we've had for so many years
of like how can we make school lunches
more disgusting
and um right I think they did a great
shot I would never I would never eat a
bug and you got this is coming from a
guy that eats on stage every night
wait a minute
I think you do better than that but you
don't want it you don't want to try the
bugs Lauren no way really you don't want
him either no yeah I mean I would you
know what if they weren't pushing them I
might do it just because I like to do
kind of strange things right and I'd say
yeah I'll eat bugs but now I don't want
to eat them because I know that these
people are going to force them on us
what is that supposed to replace I mean
you'd have to eat the whole thing of
bugs to be slightly full right yeah okay
it's protein there's meatless Mondays
that has caught on Taco Tuesday no no
tofu Tuesday worm Wednesday that's where
we're headed and I think introducing it
in school
great idea because eating bugs is like
the kids get excited about that right
yeah bugs you're so excited it's cheaper
we're having a school lunch problem
being able to afford it just give them
bugs
normalize it early change their behavior
early that's where we're headed it is so
true that's where we're headed I do not
approve but we're kind of saying it
jokingly right but that is what if you
looked at the video in the Netherlands
they are introducing it to kids because
they do want them to get used to this
kind of and they because they I think
they want them to be introduced to
laboratory food in the end they want to
take over all the Farms they want to put
the solar dishes on there and they want
to feed us bugs and Factory food what do
you think well I don't want to have I
had a late lunch so instead of the
mealworm do you have like a snack worm I
mean lighter yeah which is the light
kind of a appetizer these are more if
you have a between meal try the worm
which is those look scarier to me
what they try to say is
well people eat it in other parts of the
world yeah parts of the world those
people are trying to leave
people don't come to America and say you
know what I miss from back home oh those
those meals with bugs all over them they
don't we have better food that's why
they're going to Europe these the recent
immigrants to Europe would say this is
why I left you know my home Village I
was tired they don't say you know go
great with this how about some typhoid
fever that would that would really make
me homesick yeah well they always try to
say uh well the nutritional benefit they
say it's it's high in protein but people
aren't going to swallow something just
because you say it's high in protein
trust me I've tried that line oh my
goodness it doesn't work
I think you're right
this is part of a plan to say oh we'll
make you eat gross stuff because we're
going to tell you what you can eat we're
going to tell you what you can drive
we're going to tell you where you can go
it's all just if they can talk eating
bugs they can talk into a lot of other
things yes I think this is Emily it's
part of the when I say I'm you know
we're joking in this segment but I do
believe that the globalists I'm not
going to get conspiracy here they've
said they want to move the world to a
non-meat diet and they are willing to
push right right and again I think it's
ignoring uh the basic economics and the
basic livelihood needs of Americans so
you know we're talking about global
Elites but focusing on this country for
a moment the farm industry has been
absolutely gutted absolutely eroded by
in particular this Administration
without acknowledging livelihoods and
dependencies and then the increase of
regulations that have had such a
horrible impact on the farming industry
so again it's sort of like ignoring a
really again a hemorrhaging problem in
the society in this country and then
providing some sort of alternative that
nor is that Americans are suffering
Farmers work their tails off all day
long to provide food for Californians I
mean for Americans sorry that slipped
out um and another another example
um sort of tangentially but in the area
of Yuma Arizona that area provides 90
percent of the leafy greens that this
country consumes in the winter time and
that's being absolutely decimated by the
illegal immigration coming through on
the southern border because they have to
adhere rightly so to pathogens regulated
by the administration so one farmer
reported to Fox News he lost a hundred
grand in one week because everyone was
traipsing through the fields so again
the issues that are impacting the
farming industry here that are impacting
Farmers here Foods on the table here now
we're given a solution that's like oh
we're just going to pick bugs nothing to
see here eat your eat your your crickets
and your mealworms eat your tofu while
Americans suffer it's a shell game and
it's elitist just like you're saying hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else